[Musique]
l'histoire de leur migration passent
souvent inaperçues mais pour une fois
leur parcours et leurs visages sont
sortis de l'ombre des élèves en classe
de francisation dans trois écoles
secondaires de longueuil ont écrit des
textes b écrire notre première journée
de l'arbre à notre pays et notre opinion
sur les
le monde arrivait de colombie l'an
dernier samuel se fait bien comprendre
en français ça fait juste pas que cette
marina que je sais une claquette je sais
pas quand
j'ai créé tanguy
ça peut limiter les audiences à c'est un
bon texte à moi qu'on qui je suis
c'est joli mais les mauvais omar ahmad a
créé la portée les derniers quarts en
électronique aux sons insolites et plus
de 90 élèves ont écrit leur histoire et
certains ont accepté de la lire en
public
je viens de jordanie
pour le moment je suis en classe de
questions écrites et fiers de ce qu'ils
ont vécu aussi cet enseignant en classe
d'accueil est admiratif c'est
l'ouverture la soif d'apprendre
à chaque année la plupart des élèves
maintenant que monsieur quand est ce que
quand est-ce que je parlais québécois
quand est-ce que je vais aller au
régulier c'est leur but si donné
l'opportunité d'y vivre qu'avec anouilh
à nos enfants ce quelque chose de 10
kg par les mots des adultes en classe de
francisation ont également participé au
projet voit migrantes et d'ivan batista
a voulu parler des deuils qui l'a fait
en quittant le brésil il ya sept mois
oui mais motifs beaucoup j'ai plein
beaucoup parlent d'un pelé process
décrit parfois ça rappelle des souvenirs
un deuil qu'il fallait faire
un arrachement des racines qu'il faut
replanter de nouveau et tout ça c'était
comme une aventure à revivre à travers
l'écriture les invités ont pu lire les
textes sur leur téléphone je me sens
extrêmement privilégié d'avoir accès à
toutes ces histoires de vie locale et
les élèves aient eu la générosité de
partager un morceau de leur histoire
avec nous qu'on a vraiment intérêt à
faire partager avec dans des événements
comme celui qu'on vit aujourd'hui de
leur donner la parole pour que l'on
comprenne un plus si vite qu'on
développe la compassion pour
pour leur réalité sur m'appelle pauline
et j'ai écrit un slam pour toutes les
femmes on compte bien répéter
l'expérience qui a engendré de la fierté
et de l'espoir le père jean histoire les
jambes mais moi femme forte et tu
resteras toujours merci à sintra et qui
aura aussi peut-être bâtit des ponts ici
à nourrice dépasser radio-canada
longueur
[Applaudissements]